hey guys it is Monday my name is Jeff
I'm Dan and you're watching games but
news if he is what's happening today
if the cell was battlefront to beta was
too far away for you to really dig into
this past weekend yeah I have done you a
solid and extended it a couple of days
we used to have a rebel pilots helmet
this is all I could find was left with a
costume so the beta which was supposed
to wrap up today will now close this
Wednesday October 11th no word on if
there will be extra content added to the
beta but hey at least you can blast more
droids now the beta features three maps
and game modes with the 40 player mode
galactic assault playing out on feed the
objective based strike mode on takodana
and the ship one star fighter assault in
the space above fondle you can also try
out the new class system and other stuff
in arcade mode Star Wars Battlefront 2
is out on ps4 Xbox one and PC on
November 17th if you're bummed about the
relatively meager catalogue of games on
the SNES mini well it looks like some
hackers have come to your rescue we're
doing props today props day so I didn't
pop out far enough you may remember the
same thing happening with the NES
classic when it was released the SNES
method to hack the console and add more
games to it uses the same tool hack Qi
and games can be loaded by connecting
the SNES mini to a PC it's also possible
to add box art and a controller shortcut
to return the system to the home screen
rather than having to press the reset
button on the console be warned though
doing anything like this runs the risk
of breaking your console the SNES mini
classic isn't experiencing the same
stock shortages as the NES plastic
advant ender have pledged more stock so
that everyone will have the chance to
grab one we're tracking the supply of
the system's over on GameSpot so if you
are having trouble finding one we can
help you out
finally the tail end of this weekend
brought a few leaked skins from the
overwatch Halloween event thing that's
coming we don't have any overwatch props
but we have a statue of zelda sorry
proper so far Blizzard is only
officially shown off upcoming spooky
skins for Reaper and machree but if
waiting is not your thing
the Internet has delivered reddit use
them and numerous the notes or something
reposted the images which were served up
as adverts on Facebook they show off his
sweet demon skin for Symetra May as as
yunxi and a bright purple Cthulhu look
for all youth in yar domains this is
probably where we should point out that
Blizzard hasn't released these
officially so there isn't
they may turn out to be fake but fingers
crossed that doesn't happen because
they're excellent Halloween terror 2017
kicks off on October 10 on PC ps4 and
Xbox one and will run until November 2nd
let us know what you think of these
skins and which ones you'd like to see
Blizzard add for All Hallows Eve that's
everything we have for you today do
enjoy the rest of your day and we'll be
here tomorrow morning to bring you all
the news you need so we'll see you guys
then it's amazing that's not it don't
try again nope nope that's that one
that's not a thing
that's that one okay I do this